today we're going to be speaking with
Rhys Peck who's an associate professor
at the City University of New York and
also author of the book Fox populism
branding conservatism as working class
really appreciate your time and for
being here today
yeah my pleasure so to start with you
know my um my understanding of the
history of political media including
sort of as described by the book waves
of rancor which starts with the use of
low power FM and talk radio and and sort
of all the way through where we are now
is that the political right and the
political left have used media
differently part of that has to do with
ownership structure and issues related
to money and financing but part of it
also has to do with the right quite
frankly having better I would argue more
effective sort of bumper sticker phrases
that better lend themselves to some
forms of media can you talk a little bit
about the current landscape and how you
would sort of distinguish the way the
political right and left use media
yeah well first off the right it's hard
to talk about the kind of right versus
left media you really have to think
about a kind of a liberal corporatist
Center that dominates the mainstream
Legacy Media and then this massive
right-wing sector that's always been
there for multiple generations and then
this little sliver of truly leftist
media and these alternative spaces so
you kind of have to break it down on a
tripartite uh model it's harder to talk
about like left media versus liberal
Centrist media
um but the left media uh in terms of the
history of alternative left media I mean
today there's a common sense notion that
the mainstream media is liberal as a
liberal bias but if you took a time
machine to the 1930s when they talked
about the bias of the press it was
always the capitalist press or the
conservative press and so labor unions
and leftists had to create these
alternative Revenue models had to kind
of fight their way to get on radio
and it's always been this uphill uphill
battle I mean if you're critical of
capitalism and the media system you
exist in is commercial in nature right
um it's an uphill battle for funding for
legitimacy uh and so that's largely the
history of the left like the true left
kind of alternative media the
conservative media uh inversely I guess
would say when you have this
pro-business class uh free market
ideology the wins that you're back right
you're basically telling media
Executives and billionaire donors that
they're the moral history I mean they're
the moral Heroes they're the job
creators so they're going to look kindly
on you in your in your content uh and so
but I don't think that structural
analysis it can only go so far and I
think leftists throw their hands in the
air and they say well we don't have the
same billionaire backing we don't have
the same funding and I think you're very
right to say there are things in which
left media creators do to tie their own
hands to shoot themselves in the foot in
terms of messaging in terms of style in
terms of narrative that that has really
catapulted the right is it I completely
agree with you they're kind of more
sophisticated in terms of their
communication and media strategies can
you talk a little bit give some examples
of that and you know I mean when I talk
to others in the left media space and
when I talk about that just to be really
clear I'm not talking about MSNBC MSNBC
is sort of like a Democratic Party
Center left positioning corporate profit
motives that are identical to Fox News
Etc even if some of their policies are
different certainly their editorial
perspective is different but when I talk
to other people in like left Independent
Media there are many who say I would
gladly accept the millionaire or even
billionaire donors of the daily wire if
they came to me and said hey I want to
give you money to do exactly what you're
doing the Counterpoint to that is those
who say no no no by the very nature of
having those millionaires or
billionaires supporting you you would
not be able to do what you're doing
that's the difference between what the
left wants to espouse and what the right
wants to espouse so how much of it is
that the messaging of the left is not
appealing to those monied interests
versus something else
well I would say that there was no
shortage of millionaire billionaire uh
money for writing media in the 1950s and
60s and 70s but they were not nearly as
successful and so if it was all money
and donations then how come William F
Buckley wasn't you know uh a kind of
populist tabloid hit or how come the
first generation the conservatives were
so ineffective their media before
Limbaugh before Fox News was largely on
the margins it was a boutique kind of
segment of the conservative movement uh
it was only when you get to Limbaugh
where you see this blend of kind of
profitability they're they're a
profitable commercial entertainment
product and then conservative ideology
and it's when the conservatives really
with Murdoch's influence Embraces
tabloid style in popular style and
integrated insights from tabloid the
public affairs genres like talk radio or
tabloid television that the right attain
this kind of level of cultural dominance
and prevalence that it did and so I
think there's lessons to be learned from
the left right the left has this
inflexible commitment to this kind of
upper middle class educated uh imagined
audience in mind when they're when
they're designing their style they're
designing their kind of consumer appeals
and they're averse to this tabloid uh
aesthetic they're averse to kind of
populist modes of Engagement and I think
that's you know the the success of the
ride is largely a story with them
shifting toward a different style that's
more conducive to mass taste and and
kind of working class uh identity so
going back like what are the stylistic
mistakes that you think the left is
making that limit the appeal
well I think the left in especially when
you know there was this coming to Jesus
moment when uh George W bush won his
second term and and that was when you
see this explosion of kind of anti-fox
Media Ventures we got to do something
about Fox you get you know air America
is launched you know you get uh Jon
Stewart kind of coming in into his own
and critiquing and then you get a um you
know Oberman a little later and so
there's this moment where they're like
we need an Unapologetic kind of form of
progressive media to counter what fox is
doing I think my critique there is they
went all in on sarcasm and comedy in
this kind of ironic style that was the
way they were going to be popular
appealing and that has its uses and we
all like to a degree the satirical style
but I think it's limited when you have
other ways you can speak to people with
sincerity with emotional expressiveness
with recruiting certain personalities
that don't come from Prestige sectors of
the journal isn't filled and that's
exactly what fox did MSNBC had a slight
moment of flirtation with popular styled
hosts with Jake Huger and Dylan radican
and Ed Schultz uh and those shows did
good they they were they they had pretty
good ratings but it was I would say it's
because of their middle Brown taste
culture that it was off brand with MSNBC
they were trying to appeal to this
educated affluent uh demographic and
they didn't want to
um you know uh alienate them with this
populist sensibility uh and so I think
that that that's the key to me and every
time the left kind of plays with this
they generally abandon those kind of
hosts those kind of styles
George lakov has a perspective where
media aside
he argues that some of the arguments of
the right are just structurally better
suited to commercial media like a couple
examples would be hey abortion's murder
so it should be banned and on the left
it's like well you know we've got to
talk about viability and then you have
to understand sort of like the 40-week
pregnancy and uh mammalian gestation and
we have to draw it's not like a good
bumper sticker phrase or hey the taxes
it's my money let me keep my money
whereas the left is like well yes once
societies get large enough some roles
need to be centralized and so we have to
find the right tact right it's like so
he makes a more Linguistics or that that
sort of approach is how how important is
that versus like strategic media
decisions that are made by left and
right
I think it's critical you know I'm not
you know Lake off the insides of
lakehoff is that the first way we
interface with politics is often through
these moral registers it's not through
these like nuanced policy discussions or
what the facts are we really start with
Aesthetics and moral frames and then we
move to the policies those things it's
not that those things don't matter it's
just the way in which people interface
and the sequencing that they they kind
of come to engage in politics through
and and I and I I agree I mean there's
other civil rights leaders like uh
Reverend Barber who's excellent he's
he's been calling for the progressives
to develop what he calls a kind of
universal moral language and it doesn't
mean when you speak in these moral terms
you have to abandon Nuance or complexity
it's just to recognize that that is
engaging from the from up front right
that you're really laying out these kind
of positions and the right is really
good at recognizing not just speaking in
a moralistic way but recognizing what
moral political stories have had
resonance over time all right they're
very good at looking at like you just
mentioned
um this idea that I work hard and I
deserve the fruits of my labor right
there's there's a way you could frame
that in a left-wing way yeah the labor
movement works hard and they're they're
the ones that create wealth right you
could use that same moral frame like FDR
did but the right captures it co-ops and
then turns that into a story about the
fruits of Labor is really giving these
business people and the job creators
like all their hard work and so we need
not to tax them because they're the most
productive segments of society so the
ride is like very Savvy at recognizing
which narratives have resonated and been
recycled over political history and
where the left kind of shuns these
things in what the name of the
intellectual complexity or that it's too
hokey or corny
um and I just think that again that's
another way and yet they're they're
shooting themselves in the foot what do
you make strategically about the recent
Focus From the Republican party in Media
on the culture War stuff and he woke the
trans issues you know men and women's
sports as they like to call it Etc you
know a lot of the rhetoric is the same
rhetoric that was assigned to gay men 10
years ago that has just moved on now and
taken a little bit of a different tone
but do you think that from a media
studies perspective
um that it is a logical thing for the
right to be doing
temporarily or even on the medium term
or is it a mistake strategically
it all depends on if you know Murdoch
has always been very good at taking
something that seems
um uh you know somewhat Petty like M M's
being having you know uh you know
androgynous boots on or something like
that and everyone on the last the left
laughs at it right we're like oh it's so
ridiculous they care about these little
things but it's the way in which they'll
take something that is palpable and
mundane and every day and connect it to
the broader world of politics and that
actually makes politics more palpable
gives it texture and so they're only
successful if they just get two in the
weeds with CTO with CRT and trans issues
and don't connect it to these broader
narratives about how liberals look down
on us and they're part of the educated
Elite and they're the campus-based crowd
and we're the working class crowd that's
when those kind of cultural War
narratives has pack their biggest punch
but it's it's like when I look at the
Santas for example he just lacks that
ability to take those issues and kind of
turn them into broader class narratives
about elitism and about we're on the
side of authentic people and normal
people uh and he's just overly online
and it just seems like it starts to seem
like you're actually just uh your your
tactic is too naked you're just
scapegoating you're creating a scapegoat
for the sake of creating a scapegoat and
it doesn't feel like it has as broad or
populous message where Trump is very
good at exploiting those class cultural
tensions between the college educated
and the non-college educated class so I
think that's where they they're the best
is when they can package it in some sort
of larger populist class critique it's
at its worst when it just is nakedly
bigoted and nakedly
um uh a kind of subculture of the right
that they're obsessed with an extreme
kind of religious subculture speaking of
like the online media Space versus kind
of like outside of it one of the
conversations I had with my audience
during the 2020 Democratic primary was
that spending a lot of time on Twitter
and Reddit would likely give you
uh an over emphasized perspective on how
popular Bernie Sanders is within the
Democratic party and I had the belief
and I think there was polling to Bear it
out that people who are just like
working in Michigan and then picking up
their kids and going home they're not
necessarily on Twitter and Reddit in the
same way if they're on it at all and
that Joe Biden's support among the
Democratic party voters is likely much
higher than it seems and this seemed to
be the case now yes to some degree there
was this coordinated everybody got out
of Joe Biden's way after South Carolina
like that's that's true but I think the
point kind of Still Remains there has
this online discourse actually become
deceptive in terms of figuring out what
quote what people care about maybe not
only on the left but also on the right
in the sense that I don't know that that
many Republican voters the sorts of
people that kind of want like a Chris
Christie or a Mitt Romney are that
engaged with like the so-called men and
women sports thing or the anti-woke has
online really distorted what people care
about
I mean I think undeniably you know I
think that what when you really get to
the 2016 election which is really this
important pivotal shift I think in our
media culture and our politics where you
know you're no longer you know seeing
Obama dance with Ellen Degeneres and and
Hillary Clinton you know goes on stage
with Beyonce it's like this is that old
kind of monoculture model right the
vestiges of the network era where you
could still do that kind of politics
what we see in 2016 is the online
fringes start to emerge and have
outsized influence kind of erasing this
Normie kind of middle brow political uh
center right and and so you it's it
creates this deception that they're
bigger or they're more representative of
both uh their respective political sides
than they actually are and I think
you're right I I kind of was guilty of
that too when you when you consume
Bernie kind of align media so much you
know when the 2020 election happened I
realized that there are people that
actually have much more cemented demo
pro-democratic party normally loyalties
uh MSNBC and CNN actually did have some
power regardless of all the calls that
they're dying they're dead they're
irrelevant yeah you know I think they
show they're still kind of shaping what
your average middle of the road
Democratic voter thinks
um and so I'm with you I mean I think
there is
um there is an overconfidence sometimes
with the kind of alternative political
media spheres but with that said uh it
is undeniable that people are cord
cutting it's undeniable that cable is in
Decline and that even it's the writing's
on the wall even those organizations
have tried to do an over-the-top
streaming model Fox Nation CNN plus uh
they're seeing how the independent
alternative sphere is getting larger and
larger and larger and wielding more
political influence so I think we're in
this moment of transition right so it's
hard to prognosticate like what's what
or who's listening to who who's who's
driving the agenda
um it's much more unclear than it was
back in 2008 or even at the beginning of
2016. that's for sure
we've been speaking with associate
professor at the City University of New
York Reese Peck also author of the book
Fox populism branding conservatism as
working class Reese really appreciate
your time and insights today
thank you thank you for having me